what do you think about that uh mutually
sure destruction
that very simple almost to the point of
caricaturing game theory idea that does
seem to be
at the core of why we haven't blown each
other up yet with nuclear weapons
do you think there's some truth to that
this kind of
stabilizing force of mutually shared
destruction and do you think that's
gonna
hold up
through the 21st century
i mean it's it has it has held yes
there's there's definitely truth to it
that it was a
you know it's a nash equilibrium yeah
are you surprised it held this long um
isn't crazy
it is crazy when you factor in all the
like near-miss accidental firings
yes that's
makes me wonder like you know you know
are you familiar with the like quantum
suicide thought experiment
where it's basically like uh you have a
you know like a russian roulette type
scenario uh
hooked up to some kind of quantum event
you know
particle splitting um or paraparticle
splitting and
if it you know if it goes a then the gun
doesn't go off and it goes b then it
does go off and it kills you
because you can only ever be in the
universe assuming like the everett
branch you know multiverse theory you
will always only end up in the in the
branch where you continually make you
know option a comes in but you run that
experiment enough times it starts
getting pretty damn you know out of the
the tree gets huge there's a million
different scenarios in but you'll always
find yourself in this in the one way it
didn't go off
and
uh
and so from that perspective you
you are essentially immortal
because someone and you will only find
yourself in the set of observers that
make it down that path yeah so it's it's
that that doesn't mean
it doesn't
that does doesn't mean you're you're
still not going to be [ __ ] at some
point in your life
no i'm not i'm not advocating like that
we're all immortal because of this it's
just like a fun thought experiment and
the point is it like raises this thing
of like these things called uh observer
selection effects which bostrom nick
bostrom talks about a lot and i think
people should go read um it's really
powerful but i think it could be
overextended that logic i'm not sure
exactly how it can be i just feel like
you can get
you can um overgeneralize that logic
somehow well no i mean it leads you into
like solipsism
which is a very dangerous mindset again
if everyone like falls into solipsism of
like well i'll be fine
that's a great way of creating a very
you know
self-terminating environment um but my
point is is that with the nuclear
weapons thing um there have been at
least i think it's 12 or 11 um
near misses of like just stupid things
like
uh there was moon rise over norway
and it made weird reflections of some
glaciers in the mountains which set off
i think the alarms of norad
norad radar and that put them on high
alert nearly ready to shoot and it was
only because um the head of the russian
military happened to be at the u.n in
new york at the time that they go like
well wait a second why would why would
they fire now when their guy is there it
was only that lucky happenstance which
doesn't happen very often where they
didn't then escalate it into firing and
there's a bunch of these different ones
stanislav petrov like saved the person
who should be the most famous person on
earth because he's probably on
expectations saved the most human lives
of anyone like billions of people by
ignoring russian orders to fire because
he felt in his gut that actually this
was a false alarm and it turned out to
be you know very hard thing to do um and
there's so many of those scenarios that
i can't help but wonder at this point
that we aren't having this kind of like
selection effect thing going on because
you look back and you're like geez
that's a lot of near misses but well of
course we don't know the actual
probabilities that they would have lent
each one would have ended up in nuclear
war maybe they were not that likely but
still the point is it's a very dark
stupid game that we're playing um and
it is
an absolute moral imperative if you ask
me to get as many people thinking about
ways to make this like very precarious
because we're in a nash equilibrium but
it's not like we're in the bottom of a
pit you know if you would like map it
topographically um it's not like a
stable ball at the bottom of a thing
we're not an equilibrium because that
we're on the top of a hill with a ball
balanced on top and just any little
nudge could send it flying down
and you know nuclear war pops off and
hellfire and bad times
on the positive side life on earth will
probably still continue and another
intelligent civilization might still pop
up maybe
yeah
depend pick your x-risk depends on the
x-rays nuclear war sure that's one of
the perhaps less bad ones uh
green goo through synthetic biology very
bad we'll turn
you know destroy all uh
you know organic matter
uh
through you know it's basically like a
biological uh paperclip maximizer or so
bad or ai
type you know mass extinction thing as
well would also be shh they're listening
you